we've been doing a lot about this type
of stuff you put in your body's
chemicals that were putting in high
fructose corn syrup is in everything we
can't have sugar anymore
you have to drink corn when you're
having soda and a lot about the
chemicals that we eat and I saw this
great list of all these crazy crazy
chemicals that we're putting in our body
with things that we eat let's look at a
couple of them
so this is dimma Thole poly siloxane how
was that that was pretty good you guys
feel good about that it is a chemical
used in silicon which is found in silly
putty and breast implants it's also used
as a filler ingredient in chicken
nuggets chick-fil-a sandwiches
McDonald's fries taco bell cinnamon
twists and diet coke sprite dr. pepper
and Fanta sodas miss order reminds me of
the pink slime story that we've done
that everybody knows about
and now McDonald's says they don't use
pink slime and they even put that video
out about their chicken nuggets and they
show you how there's no pink slime but
it is it's just great slime it's tough
it's still pretty disgusting so actually
before we move on to the others this
stuff in particular I know that a lot of
the commenters are gonna say it's been
proven that it's fine as long as you
don't eat it constantly all the time but
nonetheless right do you like the idea
of putting that stuff in your body I
think that we are eating that stuff
constantly too which is you can't even
make that argument because most of
America is consuming all those things
it's such a high high level I mean I
don't know how you look at that list of
you know chick-fil-a sandwiches and a
dr. pepper and think that there isn't
chemicals and I was like I don't think
anybody's being like oh really I don't
even really eat or drink anything on
that list I have my occasional Taco Bell
they're not there's not so many of them
in New York so I don't have it nearly as
much as when I lived here but anything
on that list I almost never have pick it
up somewhere else yeah right when you're
eating but so all the people that will
comment below and say well you guys
don't understand science we've proven
that these chemicals are okay even in
higher doses than you think
you think either way it's we should be
in it regardless right I mean look the
fast-food Lobby and the soda Lobby or
you know though they can convince you
that any chemicals are fine I think that
those come those chemicals are terrible
I mean I would advocate that everybody
you know eats natural foods
comes from farms nearby them and I mean
that's sort of you know as you can tell
from my sweater that's the lifestyle
that I try to live but you know the grid
Punk I know that's why I should do
actually you to bring me into being off
the grid or correspondent yeah obviously
everyone can't do exactly what brain is
saying for financial reasons I want to
throw that out there because every time
we say that people start going crazy
about that and that's totally legit ok
let's look at a couple others we've got
l-cysteine which is used to improve the
texture of commercial dough for many
breads and other baked goods the source
is derived from dissolved human hair
mostly from China of course or duck
feathers I mean how the next one's even
worse but but how do they even come up
with that how did someone think we are
going to take human hair and dissolve it
and then make it into a chemical that
we're gonna use there who is this just
mad science it sounds like it I mean how
do you did someone like burn their hair
and the dough was better and they're
like oh I don't have time to get the
hair out of the dough but this tastes
amazing and if we don't have enough
human hair let's use some of those duck
feathers and is that funny you go to a
restaurant if there's a hair in your
soup or you have freak out yet we don't
have a problem if it's dissolved that
you don't see it not a problem and now
the third one and this may be the winner
Kasturi 'm which is also known as beaver
anal gland juice just take a moment and
let that seep in no pun intended
it it is natural flavoring which
basically means is anything yeah what is
natural as long as it comes from nature
and it isn't created in a lab so
technically this is natural this is not
a chemical castoreum comes from a
beavers anal gland and is used as a
natural flavoring in foods and beverages
like ice cream typically as vanilla
strawberry or raspberry Travon I feel
you know about this because before we
started the show you immediately said
the raspberry thing I saw that online
because I loved raspberry ice tea and I
was like oh my god I should never drink
who was eating a beavers ass and like
vanilla a little bit like raspberry
right like I gotta tell someone about
this
we're missing out okay maybe somebody
ate a beavers ass like oh this is pretty
good I want him but then he thought I'm
gonna tell somebody I guess is the we
don't know how we have enough beavers in
America anymore I mean I understand
rings from the Hudson project how do you
get them to sit still that's it they're
pretty like crazy angry animals yeah
they just sit still long enough to rub
an ice cream cone on the butter I mean
really the what the [ __ ] what is this
why are we doing this what you look I
get it not everyone can do the farm
table thing not everyone even has a
Trader Joe's and I'm sure Trader Joe's
uses some of this stuff but but I'm just
saying not everybody has access to
something a little more decent right but
how did this happen how did it cuz we do
this more in America a lot of stuff that
we put in our food here is banned in the
EU and many other places what is it
about American culture well I think I'm
gonna go back to the point about you
know just trying to eat sort of a better
lifestyle instead of just saying you
know people can't afford that stuff I
mean you look at you need to look at the
bigger problem in America which is that
you have these you know vast food
deserts where people don't have access
to you know fruits and vegetables and
people are surviving off bodegas with
the spicy Cheetos and and and soda like
that so I mean there's a bigger problem
at hand that really as a country we need
to refocus on the foods that people are
eating because otherwise you're gonna
continue to get these kind of chemicals
that are gonna be forced in I mean the
percentage of how much you know high
fructose corn syrup is and every single
thing that we eat is just crazy and then
you look at who is controlling that
Lobby and who's growing corn and you
know it starts to become pretty clear
that there's a you know there's a vast
corn conspiracy that's happening in this
country isn't making people you know
sick so it's not a vast right-wing
conspiracy it's a massive conspiracy are
you gonna still drink your raspberry tea
I mean after we I mean we're talking
about is now I probably had a few things
I'm thinking that I mean like it's hard
to give up I think it's I think it's a
liberty thing for Americans because it's
just like the soda thing in New York or
people are like you know it's my right
to drink a 55 ounce soda if I want to or
like the people who get mad at Michelle
Obama for just saying telling your kids
to eat better or eat vegetables
sometimes like how dare you tell me to
eat
food like I went by when he eat butter
fried steaks I'm gonna eat but like yeah
or cigarettes what your full exactly
like stop anybody like they they are so
hung up on their freedom being taken
away that they don't realize the message
is actually good like which amendment is
it that you have the freedom to have
beaver anal gland it's like sick what
the six again that's the one all right
final thought on this how long if we
took a caveman and we brought him here
today and we fed him our stuff does he
last two days does he die literally in
two days I mean to his to his benefit
there are those CrossFit people who are
on the kid probably find a good but yeah
he would die immediately yeah I mean
does this just explain why we have all
these crazy diseases and then we take
all these crazy pills that give us other
diseases and then we take other pills to
mask the other thing but also be honest
the cave men's life expectancy was
probably 17 years old at that point so I
think he'd be pretty he'd be okay yeah
yeah let's see yeah I should try it out
so how long you think - what do you
think two days three days I think yeah I
think he's got like a a week at least
but he's gonna be excited for that week
only bouncing off the wall you can have
animal style fries works he's gonna be
Burgess in his head beer on a stick